[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody how's it going John Luke
here joined by Jake
we're playing next machina next machina
the music is so good oh.just we good
yeah yeah let me I have to lower it back
up yeah now we have to put a little
about but anyway so we're gonna do some
co-op if you guys have any questions
leave it in the comments the game is out
came out yesterday yes and it's really
rad yeah I um I finally played it last
night
and I move out of the way that's that's
annoying on PC yeah mouse keeps popping
up and I was uh you guys kept talking
about good it was but like watching it
else is like I don't know if I would
like this game just because know
sometimes these 26 years don't do
anything anything for me but the
movement just feels so good yeah I put
it on it experience this game isn't
difficult so we might have to issues
probably not getting them
I'm blue I am yellow it's kind of a melt
a little bit of a mask yeah and we
apologize if we're not watching the chat
as much as we probably should
right between school sections will
present aggravated but I did see someone
asked what exactly is this well it's
Prince tix shooter it's very much in the
style of Robotron 2084 is actually
almost remake of it I've never played I
haven't played electrons before either
but I played smash TV with I also have
white fantasy which is by Eugene Jarvis
and he actually helped make this - oh
cool that's all epidemiology
like the laser did you know if you - at
the end right when that server closes in
oh really I don't know because I've been
doing it I don't know if we can get our
human face
[Music]
detonator
I wouldn't miss them
and we do share lives this matter
detecting movies here
we definitely more experience with this
Daniel I played a lot of the beta
I'm not suit like Peter in the office
which is really good
[Music]
right uh do you know what's different
from the beta look at the change much so
some little things that they've added
I mean they've added new weapons they've
added new abilities I can't go into
exactly what they are but one thing I
know they did at is the last enemy is
kind of highlight a triple pink now so
you kind of know if it's the last enemy
because I collect everything
[Music]
like whole duty black ops 1 zombies
arcade it kind of does but trust me this
is better
oh yeah oh yeah I remember buying that
like I thought that was I liked the idea
behind it but just enough like that quit
the level of care and polish because you
know a little sidekick yeah we've been
losing humans left and right now it's
hard to look at chat and do this yeah
absolutely
geometry like I walked into it okay we
lost a lot of humans anyway uh yeah I'd
say like one of my favorites went to the
shooters the geometry Royals no I love I
love I feel it's human thing dang
I should've let Chama she worries they
got that on a trip that's on backwards
compatible it is some excuse to hear my
xbox one on it I remember playing it in
Forza 3 for for the pull towards the
three this one is important
nearly knew it was in Project Gotham
Racing project gotham project austin
racing yeah that's what it was
alrighty doesn't know
that was the first thing I got with my
father got that perfect are yes yep I
got bourbon dark as well but I don't I
didn't remember just liking that as much
as everyone else did but I know young
right yeah I played actually like a lot
of it and I can miss school ideas but
like going back yeah and I was looking
at your guy I know that is issues co-op
mode is that it is this game is
confusing but I'll play it's fast-paced
yeah it's one of those games that I
think doesn't work as well watch as it
is you really got to play it it's when
you watch it it's like oh what the f am
I like right it's a lot to take in
it almost seems like too much when you
actually play it it's a little bit more
reasonable XA yeah
I also feel like there's just like a
fidelity to también that doesn't really
come across watch people happen pull the
control do it she's my whole life you up
we have no lives left - so uh
Oh
who the plan is we're gonna try to get
we're gonna try to get your overstate
right
forget all the parts
oh no I died it's up to you I can look
at the Chad now all right
and since I ran out of lives it's all
you know really yeah I got a bicep at
the Boston
[Music]
I will be checking chats if anyone has
any questions at least for right
non-human humans here a lot faster with
on the harder difficulties another
weapon spread Peter was saying about
like enemies behave differently yeah
someone Thursday rode my chair thank you
whoa and now says they love the music I
love using yeah actually on Spotify now
- if you're interested I think it's on I
don't know if it's on iTunes yet but it
sounds like they're getting it there but
I recommend getting we've got Spotify
giving it a listen
really good
[Music]
the first and second boss in this game
of
I agree but the third one out of me now
and everyone is very very well complete
although in the beta third one was much
harder a little bit yeah it got toned
down I'm pretty in must've because Rob
and I were playing on experience passing
it off and we could not not kill
anything all right
this after two time back we've got no
lodge though
things every will have a continued
sure we actually 9090
I want to watch one of these I can't
wait for like people get really good to
watch those like no skip runs right yeah
that's actually cool feature too is you
can pretty much watch like any of the
high scores that's how we actually
learned that you can now
I know how do you get that human in the
middle I actually don't have to oh boy
oh she got take it out and now our
points go back to zero well you know
what we're just trying to get through as
much as we can don't worry too much run
score as painful as that is it's so
painful
I loved snatching humans out from those
things
apparently getting through the whole the
whole thing is actually not that long
yeah no not an hour
sounds about right our reviewers said of
talking about like going really fast I
was looking at you going really fast
like 40 minutes Oh
what the mail
a human I'm so hot it will kick ass
business game man
twenty dollars oh I have no idea
oh you guys should have put it on rookie
okay the baseline experience
oh you're dead I'm dead dead yeah
launcher
you know
I did
oh stop dan you both blew up yeah all
right that's right yeah wait what oh
Jesus oh I dashed through it yeah you
can touch through that I don't know why
you keep getting the last life did you
steal the first player spot
if you should definitely the one you're
better at this anion just like football
clearly you're doing better than I I'm
not saying any team is oh sorry one step
at a time
human loss
[Music]
there you go Thanks multiplayer up
that's not
all these and suck
that table -
this latter detective
Oh
[Music]
you
Oh
oh I was looking at you
triple dash is so key Oh
Oh
[Music]
all right back in it
Oh
[Music]
triple dash
so much oh boy
i'ma FN t-rex says this I would play
absolutely man it's good worth it
a pleasant surprise I would say I was
really proud this game kind of came out
of nowhere for me at least
you saw it like a while ago I played it
when they announced it at a PSAs X right
and I played it there and I was like
this game is like this game is going to
be fantastic and I was telling people
about it and then they did a beta and we
got beta access more people tried it out
I was like yeah that's pretty good and
now seems like yesterday almost everyone
was playing it in the office yeah yeah
but our story is going to be [ __ ] no
yeah
those things are paying one of these
rail make trails yeah that our shot
are you back I think there's no friendly
fire
oh yeah it'd be terrible
[Music]
oh hey guys
[Music]
multiplier up
No dang it what happened I grabbed
detonator I didn't want it for power
shop
arguments
Oh inside
[Music]
to craft relax yeah you also got a
remember Boy shoot stuff yeah
bonus humans extra lives I think the
calm bonus human yeah how do you like
crazy so fight
Oh
they really camp them this game either
their surgery we do really good job like
placing enemies where you have yeah
moving alright boss time detonator laser
cool
I need something all right
oh the smartphone that's gonna be no
good
for that's polite
[Music]
I'm like not focusing on my aiming at
all right I'm just gonna Tashi I yeah I
hope I'm hitting hit totally oh my god
oh that was we kick that guy's butt yeah
[Applause]
complete would be a great be great game
if you're having a seizure
mm-hm can someone tell me the game name
this is called next machina kind of like
ex machina ex machinae if you don't call
it that but just add that end there an
ex machina it's for PC and ps4 and we
actually put our review up today too so
if you want to take a look at it it's
definitely worth that we gave it a 9 so
we're we aren't the only ones who are
really enjoying this game pretty
Universal here at the against my office
[Music]
whoa get rid of this thing we got the
truck
so destroying those squid things yeah
opens up on Wildboyz human oh no
these things
[Music]
once you getting the rhythm it's like
it's that lizard brain thing yeah yeah
human save secret human
Oh No what's that oh that was in behind
I was I was working like I was I was I
was really trying to make sure I hit
something and I was not looking at
myself
[Music]
dose n 67 says I think this game is
going to be my new addiction I mean the
game absolutely like just the yeah like
the the leaderboard and the speed of
this game I think just like allows you
to really like pick up and play it yeah
for sure especially I mean like if you
got into resogun and this game is right
at Riley right oh no oh I didn't die I
get as on a resogun as I feel like I
should have I think this is did I where
I I rode this one top I think the
biggest reason why didn't I don't think
I got some free resogun day was because
I got my ps4 kind of late another game
started right like Reza Khan was like
the best launch game so I got it I
launched so you think I actually would
have played it more and I were really
liking it for whatever reason it's like
it didn't yeah so this part is kind of a
pain yeah this is all new territory for
me
[Music]
Clara
[Music]
Oh No
I'm just me
[Music]
that's on me
it's alright what's up
it's like one of these just spawns out
of nowhere and gets you
[Music]
I'm full
two of them three of them whole
Oh nope Wow alright oh gee
[Music]
the old frame was just joining us we are
taking a look at the shat when when we
can pretty much from one of us dies
we'll look at the chat so I have any
questions let us know it's very hard to
divide it no attention his name but it
looks like Chad's been pretty quiet
Oh bat yeah I mean fair
already dad yep well I mean I we didn't
have enough lives me to spawn to
Callie's calling us a bunch of nerds
Kelly if you played this yet you should
play it strictly got a code
[Music]
back off oh nice
sword so it sucks yeah it does actually
too much oh no I got trapped Kelly's
gonna play tonight says it's 100% her
jam and I was not pay attention that I
was back alive I'm an effing t-rex yeah
this game is actually made by the guy
who made Robotron are made in there
helps right he didn't solely make this
yeah he made it along with housemarque
who made like we made a resin this is
Super Stardust yes I mean really that's
a pretty good fit yeah like Jason style
whoa oh I don't know what step in there
oh there's a boulder yeah Indiana Jones
part this parts hard if I do this first
time I am I don't even know what to say
ladies first time
dang
Wow I did it percent holy crap that's
impressive
[Music]
then I walked into him so unfortunately
we can't really do anything about these
lasers so Oh
don't steal these users
should've gone for the human that's my
mistake complain okay I get to focus I'm
trying to save all the humans
Mogi Clara
come check out all the human off sweets
did it
[Music]
laser
dude I know I got really close and now
that I got I took your laser yes
[Music]
very advice yeah
alright this boss is kind of tough oh
well are you dad good luck
[Music]
I'll notice so there's like guys with
the green lights on it you probably
notice if you kill all of them you get a
draw Oh
I think we might came back he'll Tron
that's a good name
so very much bullet-hell Franz
whoo whoo okay I see where this little
going thinking also it's a weird noises
here Oh God
oh no oh no hold up
[Music]
he's a laser I said Oh mommy I don't
know how it switched on me not going to
do you a whole lot of good right now
now that's what's the worst thing you
get for boss
although you're kicking ass right now I
know if I beat this first try I'm going
to be good stuff
do they just enemy difficulty based on
co-op or not I don't know I can't tell
holy [ __ ]
oh my god oh dang so close remember
started for the young I'm pretty sure
yep
alright P Oh what that see I'm useless
holy [ __ ] so Chad how's it going
it's alright I've played this boss quite
a few times now this is your first try
we have I'm like dying like instant I
don't even get to the box like that's
pathetic
Oh powershot get me that power shock oh
boy oh I'm done tell you now
since it reminds me of the old
24 yeah mention that yeah all right okay
it did because it didn't with me because
we were out of lives but and I'm dad I'm
this same time
Bennett power Shawn
Oh God
no I'm not getting a detonator not
follow that yeah Rep rubber now step our
shot
oh and I'm dead dead too you can so good
that first round see once your red
rocket launches log on just by my face I
agree
good go - oh wait I didn't get in there
good Malaysia all right that's pretty
good too
not is that especially evens bosses it's
a little bit tougher I think actually I
don't I was pretty good against for that
mate forget against a group
alright on the boss alright alright
we've got 90 continues left I don't know
if we can make it what ah
those things you gotta worry about those
squids whatever they are
oh you're back you're back oh thank you
oh the wit hit like an edge you're back
I mean I'm back alright I'm useless
good lord I'm so bad I'm so sorry
oh no damn it
yeah I shouldn't have done it I
shouldn't have done experienced we might
be here a while
thank you what
grabbed my rocket launcher there's one
human
go back
further than my guy
yeah that's like threatening that's
where I'm getting tripped up it's like
I'm not paying attention to my guy
awfully well how did I die
okay neither of us can die now
yeah those things more important just
focus on your guy and just like like
shoot where you think the enemy is right
especially like in the later part of
this yeah like right now right this very
soon just starts spitting yeah this this
stuff is
yeah there we go all right cool complete
nice work how many worlds 500k Wow done
three secret exits oh yeah so there are
like secret pathways I don't know how to
open up all of them but occasionally
you'll do something destroy something
and you'll go you'll your character will
go a different direction
I don't even know how I died I just gets
tougher because of these these rings are
a pain in the butt because you really
have to lecture take care of your
dashing
oh you're dead
rocket launcher
now I terminated yep he's right
we were terminated I can apply to any
any point in this there I go
humans
man it's those circles because they like
they go so slow that you're not worried
about it all of a sudden you just dive
up right on you oh boy
Oh God Wow I'll get the shield right
there
nice got the loved ones best
I think this is about as far as I've
gotten without getting a continue not
getting a continue to that's out getting
anything that isn't prevalent I died
is that on experience difficulty as well
no that was on rookie Oh
an experienced I've made it to the start
of this one like not at the start of his
area god
oh we got a signal okay don't know how
but
yeah I try to get all those guys nice Oh
[Music]
something else yeah
Oh does that
[Music]
honey you don't hit me I don't care
about humans anymore
I keep hearing human losses like
whatever got one though
oh my gosh oh boy
dang
[Music]
yeah I got trapped I was not going to
last
that were shot
Wow there's so many bullets going out of
there just gonna stay away from that
yeah nice
somehow I did that follow-up to you
oh no oh my humans Oh No
on
nice you're kicking ball with the power
shop grab that extra life swole could
they have that shield oh you get that
extra life
oh that's with me
[Music]
so what's the score you had finger at
your highest in the driest or oh man I'm
not sure probably pretty high I think it
was it was over damn it it was over 20
million and I think I saw Peter here had
like 36 9 I'm out of the out of the
groove now
alright alright
Oh
got a secret human though anything that
was fast
oh no didn't catch that time except you
[Music]
nice
so many humans
there's one you know and get didn't save
and he gets stolen levels big in this
game how long does it take to get
through a level Oh fans how good you are
yeah
what you said the length has been for
each each world I mean last one took uh
seven minutes we died quite a bit
[Music]
[Music]
things alright alright bad guys gotta
test
what what goes we both got hit by the
circle oh dang you're gonna do kill it
still fires of the church ring yeah
tripping me up those things that becomes
a pain oh oh I got if I don't sang
resogun on steroids I'd say that's an
accurate assessment smells the music is
awesome and yes it is oh yeah I
mentioned it before but just in case
you're joining now aw crap
it is available on Spotify and I think
iTunes soon but it is definitely on
Spotify right now because I listened to
it earlier today it's funny uh listen
next to rob and n just hearing him it
you just hear these like ah look like
just dig you know every time he dies bro
get larger I want
yeah looks like those things release
even when they die so that was what was
tripping me up is I'm like oh I killed
it I'm good and then it would just like
launch a thing
nice all right
about to fight the boss here i have not
fought this boss so okay then let's see
how we do
well no I did oh my god
what is even going on
for sir Prime
[Music]
dude oh he launches those rings his guys
nice turnaround and Ninja Tune darkens
okay
[Music]
deadfast oh hello why would the mod
delete that message I'm not sure a
message yeah I'm not sure women are we
both that but looking out and have
bandages I kind of wish they give you an
even amount alive Santa Nader that'd be
weird that because this or not know you
always get stuck with one person alive
oh I've walked right into one of those
lasers hard to watch oh yeah there you
go sure don't get the detonators
don't fall for it
oh the ring it's not hey tension oh oh I
was alive
right and then I died let me do it now
okay right here
launcher
deal with these anger it
we got rocket launcher
clémence and odd
[Music]
Wow yikes yikes I got immediately
now smart-bomb Marcone well says so
colorful yet is very colorful all the
other all the worlds have like a very
different look tombs whoo I like it are
we doing both get a rocket launch yeah
million lasers coming from every
direction though Oh on me oh no the ring
back you are I'm not
the ring
William says same career as a resogun
yes house Marquis oh my laser power shop
get laser jeez
Oh No are you still alive good alright
cool were both alive got the ring the
ring oh it's still document - the wrong
way back though nope he's tricky yeah
that loser all right I'm gonna deal with
these guys as quick as possible because
they're really annoying I'll leave you
guys yeah
alright well we got that good way yeah
that was not the sword we both got it
buddy Bubba I buy it oh no I wasn't even
I should have warned you but I was
concentrating come on
Oh Oh No what even happened it's like
the definition of bullet hell yeah
oh I'm back
[Music]
oh I knew I wouldn't make it I'm back
though right
the laser does not have that part
No
got a stay-away guy because it'll creep
up on yourself some yeah base then the
the sure khun's
rock water
Holly's is not that good I like that
much it's fine I like boys
rocket launch arrange and prioritize my
baby yeah
but
watch out for ring nice oh stop them
Oh
oh come on it's over
Oh No oh my god
well without range this is going to be
tough get the rocket launcher
is it work fart
dude so close Oh
blowing sure kids are cool yes they are
I love that couple of those or like
again G that throws those that'd be
pretty cool oh yeah it just got like a
purple skin I want say like going purple
all right I'm feeling it rocking them
yeah there we go there we go move it up
she's already going to this point
RIT yeah we got to that fast Wow
oh I walked into it was even civil as
he's moving Oh
Marathi
oh dang oh that move it's going right at
me is there a game over do you always
get continue where you left off
well eventually we'll run isolated yes
so you only have a certain plate
experience we only have a certain amount
of retries we have 99 which sounds like
a lot although we've learned through
quite a bit already just on this guy
along if you play on rookie there are
there's infinite retries but no matter
what difficulty you play on focusing at
the moment no matter what difficulties
you play on your score will reset when
you get a game over
so there's like the base experience
which is just playing it getting through
the game learning how all the levels
operate then there's the true experience
which is like trying to do it all
without getting like a game over dang
having that triple dash would be so nice
here that last one we have does a really
good run
no I got the detonator
I'm gonna think the remote detonator may
not be terrible it's so it's okay it's
just there's it a remote that there's
just always something saying it's the
remote or it's just called detonators or
is there one caller oh I don't know I
mean there's a [ __ ] I was a [ __ ] on
yeah I think the detonator is the remote
mine yeah just those smart bombs but one
it died I do not pay attention to the
fact that in the boss who automatically
just respond with spawn so it says hello
from August Oh Georgia hey how's it
going
thank you for checking this out what's
Georgia like today how's the weather
been a today's actually not bad and
yesterday was not bad but the last
couple of days have been ooh hot good no
landed on me
just got a ps4 Pro yesterday does this
game a pro sport you know I don't it
might be a good game - uh-oh
crack open your new pro with some tells
me this is pro sports
[Music]
if the NEB says my brain can't keep up
with anything that's happening right now
yeah it's definitely harder to watch
than it is to play I will say that but
yet agrees requires ton of focus hmm
sneaky sure Akins
[Music]
I walked away like trying to do this
without resetting I know Peter made it
really far I think he's got past this
without really without recited I don't
know if you did may have not done
experience may have done rookie oh I was
back alive I need to invest in a fan
yeah I have fans not enough trying to
find like a severe air-conditioner
problem is Mike my windows aren't really
flipped for like a traditional
air-conditioner that might have to get
like the tune
clanging in game on a ps4 Pro
I mean this game looks pretty good well
yeah but like all these particle effects
and you know it's got that HDR right
with all the colors like that could look
really cool yeah especially up in a
chair can be sure but yeah I don't know
if it's the
rocket launchers detonator
Shh oh my gosh I think it will I Pro
Sport cuz I'm pretty sure house martinis
other new game that they're making they
were demoing it for matter fall yeah
they were saying that that house pro
support so that this does
that's a sword not the detonator perfect
man not having range and spread makes it
a lot harder
I hate this move oh my - the wrong point
shot Oh back in
back in
yeah
all this pain
I mean no we survived that last animal
Shh God
so we're he's ya never know
someone asked what is matter fall um
matter fall is similar to this but its
side scroll side-scrolling yeah
which they actually announced before
this game it's coming out after really
yep I didn't realize I announced it
before
No
No how did I live do that
does not have enough range
yeah I wish I have a couple -
furlings for it
oh we both got smoked by that
okay into the deaf
[Music]
oh that was so birdie
Wow that
since I so really hype about Crash
Bandicoot right now that comes out
really soon doesn't it each spell suite
alright should we knock the difficulty
down can you do it without well we can't
we cannot even jump back in at this
point man
I don't know I really want to beat this
boss alright
dead as matter fall release no matter
fall is not released yet I don't
remember the exact release date I don't
think it's too far out
dang
Oh
ice these things suits Baga I feel like
very cheap it's lower I think that's
what I'm tipping up
come on bond [ __ ] dang I don't want
a smart bomb on one of the rock
oh cool want this
brain effects really cool yeah
James horn Wells's you can do it thanks
I hope so
a certain point we got I heard you know
there are two more difficulties above
this boy that's nuts
like how
guess I'll take a bow smart ball
schools close so close
all right
it's this part I'm gonna use my rock
until I can just take these things out
as soon as possible
that move is deadly
Yates
I know what's going on with the camera
but it's freaking me out yeah I don't
like it
watch out he's gonna do that right all
right Ryan
yeah Oh keep getting them
oh gosh focus on your character Oh God
rings oh boy no no no hello from
Manchester UK hello thanks for stopping
by we are currently getting our ass
handed to us by the machine oh it was so
close I don't I don't care about humans
I'm gonna grind my teeth away playing
this game
I don't want the sword I don't want the
detonator I want the leaf yeah sure
she didn't really want police to play
but it's think about as clear yeah it
was about so
Oh No
you bed Numb all right this part
damn
rapping active launcher okay
man the camera is working out in a way
that I do not care for
oh I got him watch out he's gonna land
and then do his dumb I know he's not
okay no okay we just got him to skip it
and I was hoping to do that
ah haha this is so scary
Oh dead hmm
grab my rocket launcher launcher
mine's in on middle
damn this game looks good wanna play it
but camps away storm blood I've been
doing really good things up stand what
you doing dude
yes oh my god that was so sad holy oh
wow nice work thank you
secret light wish we got a good amount
of humans all right 69 nice mm-hmm
I apologize all right the final area oh
wow yeah so like yeah even though this
game you can get through in 40 minutes
it sometimes takes longer if you're not
right at it now we've been going for
about an hour
all right take it closer
yeah
Oh
[Music]
we both got rockin so it's pretty good
yeah the problem is is it like I just
see a pickup and I'm new to this
I'm a bachina Maga - explosion before
oh I walked into the lady baby I can't
[Music]
why did I do that why that was dumb
you
can't destroy that right so I was trying
to do I'm trying to destroy it he'll do
an extra life
today
we're back there that's what
[Music]
Hey
close your eyes
weapon range was nice
cool
whipping me out
so when I have $60 game no this is not a
$60 game I think it's $20 but I'm not
trying to shoot it's not
damn
rocket launcher shield
no-ho-ho that can't can you destroy that
middle thing no at least I wasn't able
to
Oh too much
dude a camp right
how did I
by that guy
nice whoo back in it
all right dad oh that was you I thought
those me what is even happening
damn shield shield lost
oh my all right oh right away I got a -
away
does that you cannot - through that I
guess not all right immediately get away
from that stupid thing
[Music]
right I don't even know what happened
hey goob what's going on shall I shield
human want a rocket launcher or
something
uh yeah me Jake are playing co-op right
now and it is a real tough I was not
ready and died immediately
[Music]
[Music]
sorry human I don't care anymore yeah it
doesn't matter
nice that's okay
nope yeah you cannot dash through those
right no your Basques doing better than
last time uh yeah we've made it further
I think that that boss that we were
stuck on though Dube I think it was
scaled down a little bit but the boss
after him was really hard yeah made up
for it
not secret
all right you are carrying us through
here now
I spoke too soon
what
but even was that
music is still consistently good though
oh yeah
not dying a time
all right I gotta get it together oh wow
all those little swimmy dudes know
all right
[Music]
[Music]
No give me your sword pick up at a
rocket oh I hate when it does best
automatically yeah I was something on me
and I'm a scared to death it was a plug
[Music]
okay
yeah you can have that
[Music]
dang
most too much happening on this period
how long follow it I don't know let's
say oh I think that's like a bot thing
like moobot right we're it's like how
long is screwed on okay okay look at my
human alright
made it getting close to the end think
so
Oh clear heaven
no [ __ ] you what happened now stuck all
right be
side
help I hit the same thing you hit
I must walk right into that guy
all right so die
[Music]
okay oh we're at it army oh yeah okay
just getting right to it huh I thought
but I'm back oh you're right it just
starts the boss right away
though in shoot those things
Oh
I ran out of [ __ ]
with you
all right we got half of our credits
left
No
all right dead I forgot and I forgot
that it starts on the boss
thanks toward lasers on the other side
end of a power shot dead
go on
this is hectic
feels like how it makes it easier harder
ah hard to tell honestly it feels more
hectic with co-op yeah that's some way
like how you like it's a little easier
but in other way it's not doesn't feels
like properly balanced I'd say
oh my gosh
dang got hot
dad
oh that said Wow we've hardly damaged
his thing now
[Music]
on a detonator
smart bomb you know Thanks
Oh
oh you can't even if I feel guy came in
really beautiful skin the middle
oh I just destroyed one though oh okay I
thought he was doing nothing
I mean me I did this oh yeah boy
nope there you go
what I've been
oh I had one of those we got halfway
though
yeah we're getting it so so if Miguel
are you here no somebody else in the
office somewhere
come on the stream get back
oh you're right I am back magic
okay I'll rock it
and
dead Wow you go where are you
I did ID
I've guided way through all of our lives
yeah it does need damage stripping can
destroy them yeah it'd take forever that
it does I feel like it's better to just
shoot the fame the middle
[Music]
so I was playing time sucker rocket
launcher
nope
[Music]
good vulture
I feel a little extra room here
[Music]
bang
it's not easy no
okay
rocket launcher a smartphone
Oh
laser pen good enough
good nature
oh I destroyed one of the guns nice
[Music]
well I moved
just me no I'll get your
hit him no bang same point exact same
point really
I will teach it on the ground yeah I
guess I guess that's an in-joke on there
[Music]
making it tired what is this come on
it's too easy I'm so bored
actually I'm at the point where my hands
not like slipping on the I know the
trigger all right that gun is gone that
gun is gone just pelted him all right
watch out cause this thing will move we
can't shoot those but whatever
please go away after
all right now they're gonna gone all
this ones back trying to power
dawn
[Music]
Oh God
what oh there's one good hole and oh
what's there's a guy with a tie in there
so corporate metaphor
holy hell oh just out now yes it is yes
it is oh I was like I know in the zone I
don't even look at the health bar I do I
was just like so focused on my guy not
even looking at it whoa
damn it yeah took us a lot of lives
lotta lives over half of them Jake all
sweaty and jean-luc taking naps
dang what oh it's not done yet all right
I thought that was it I thought it was
through eyes are there only five world
oh my god can't stop now but very much
seemed like the end of the game
[Music]
keep going yeah oh well you can keep
going
all right get back
ah you're gone
I still think that fourth floss is the
hardest yeah I I agree got choked up
double lasers come on
mmm got smoked
Oh
[Music]
laser how many worlds are there I
thought there was five biggest if six
wonderful have enough continues to make
it do this oh we're at 45 nice oh I
think so I think
so I can't
Oh No
what blossoms out there
oh me too I take out these things quick
nope not new
[Music]
are you got this
yeah jump
great
cool
this is the pain
[Music]
Powershot to cut through there
stay with you
No
- ah
oh did not time that long
I know since there are six worlds I
guess the the Edmonton yeah Vince is you
know sick so it looks like the six one
just wasn't appearing the end maybe it's
like a secret what that final boss you
just bought very much felt like no a
finalboss finalboss yeah it looks like
the machines have invaded the humans
safe haven in space is that the plot I
don't
is there a plot of this game yeah uh
it's a lot like me automata I'm pretty
sure you'll make me cry
Oh nada alright I jump later on about it
yeah apparently a lot of people cry and
dash through that you do the same thing
dread attest to it yep yeah here's a big
one of my list now that I beat me I
finally beat horizon oh yeah
which was really good I'm glad I'm glad
I went back and finished that game yeah
I kind of came out at a strange time
opportune time really same with me oh
really
yeah pretty much anything that came out
around the same time as the switches all
the kikuna right did it again tried to
dash through there like a moral hose
Elva dl seems like a week ah goob says
didn't cry but near made me think about
life deep alright
it's more than most games will do for
you
[Music]
new saying thank boys track down by
track down by a snake boy dang this
thing is not relenting no
nope
[Music]
tracked me down
yeah
[Music]
all right
well powershot triple -
is it good are you talking about horizon
zero don't you talk about this because
this is really good riding the road on
is also really good yes nice extra life
and I'm back
[Music]
[Music]
no I don't
although something
no don't give me the freaking sword ah
that's really annoying that it does that
I hate that it does that but I was
trying to stay away from it and then it
just sucked into me
I got this stupid sword oh oh I had a
shield another shield seems perfect
today's dang there's so much going on on
screen and I like forget when you're
just Walter when you're playing hit cuz
you just focused on you yeah oh I was
just about that alright alright yeah
okay
people are talking about horizon yeah
horizons good playwright hell of a lot
of side quests in horizon zero dawn yes
there are there are only good ones to
some small right ones as well
yeah I actually 100% of the game I was
gonna do that
well that's weird I didn't actually 100%
like the the screen said like 83 but I
did every side quest I did I got all the
collectables and so I platinum the game
oh but there was a hundred percent no I
think it's good like I didn't like find
every like fireplace or whatever like
like I didn't like it it you know kind
of things so it's like I did everything
in the game so like I'm not gonna bother
to know I got platinum
I'm good I think I think when I'm most
excited for is to see because they're
definitely make a second right I think
so I would like to see that game learn a
bunch of lessons from Zelda and like
incorporate that into horizon to I think
that would be really cool we are getting
through this yeah we did it
hope kind of dude a little short one
thank it either
No we lost them like the one before what
you never stood yeah you never supposed
to lose that and then what I got again
was filling me a laser
oh I supreme AI okay it has to be the
all right
so I'm so sad Christopher actually
connected with the story and horizon yes
actually horizon actually does a really
cool thing where despite the light in
the later half of the game a lot of the
main missions actually comment on if you
dig side missions and like characters
will show up like there's a sort of like
this big climactic battle at the end of
that game and like a bunch of side care
can still show and be like I'm here to
fight with you because you know we did
this and the very like Mass Effect II
kinda way that was actually pretty cool
like I didn't expect the game to quite
go to that far I don't even know what a
monster
yeah we're not just dude this is what
madness is going on okay we're at 35 now
I'm getting a little worried
what is hitting me
okay we need to kill the octopus things
yeah okay we got the middle thing -
that's the problem what just hit me
dang
yeah I don't know if 33 is enough flex
to this
got him got him just got a crowd of
control you got it you got to get on top
of it okay
get that thing
Oh where'd I go
guide I know Becca help back there
Elsword this looks frightening
back
oh we generalize
nope dammit all right
we don't have the range game name next
machina oh oh i spawned in a pit of you
exile can't get through that guy now
okay I think you just got immediately
start heading to the lab and get kill
like that guys by that thing
dead again
okay that working oh dang it I lost it
why even hit me it's hopeless
just looking at me like what are we
gonna do hopeless
do these these credits are going down
real way up well what
Oh
[Music]
I was shot
what sword what game alright one life
all of you Jay
oh my god
okay
[Music]
no die
right into that thing
okay
[Music]
squared get the squid get the squid got
him I do track myself
[Music]
that a rocket-launching and then I got a
sword now yeah yeah did that to me
okay well that's okay she's a pretty
good there yeah I'll hit me I'll hit him
with my sword I won't do that
what I do yeah saving my breath on that
one and then I can't even hit him here
because I can't get close
No Mario you kill machinima machi now we
need you literally we do Miguel will
come in here and he'll serpents out
good
better than sword
uq0 any good I didn't play it but Peter
gave it a 9
yeah that is one that I've also been
meaning to go back I don't know if I'll
get to it because there's just so many
games but see my late son I'd really
like
[Music]
oh my gosh we're probably gonna run out
of lives before I'm him I think so yeah
we're just going to go until we beat him
run out of lives run out of lives
okay
not the sword
what to do there
since you got tell October this good
point
I'm much going out for a little bit I
dashed through that I'm also gonna try
and I'm trying to play like some older
games like I kind of want to replay like
the new order like welcome yeah I will
replay the new order no we play Metro
last light right I want to read yeah
replay Metro although that one I up good
more confident I have more time to yeah
oh yeah for sure
Mike's playing that right now
he's copying me dope I started playing
it last night in the Sun planet today
certainly after that he was saying
there's some weird issues with the the
redox version which I've never played I
don't think so I think he just it was
the black magic if he was just capturing
oh if he yeah it feels like listening to
audio for my seminar I'm [ __ ] the chat
is very quiet cuz they're all focusing
on us yeah they're so into this what
forget it
it's not happening you're indeed oh I'm
in yeah you got a point with that
rockets yes yes yes cleanly a good thing
the power
whoa how did I even survive that lucky
lucky hole just me just you it's been
just you oh my god when your relative
lives you start from the world one no
you can start from this world but you'll
start at zero points actually you might
have to keep the boss no no don't mock
the world I'm not entirely sure all
right
picking out this dude right away don't
feel like that
cool cool I got Rockets nice
dead hold that okay folks
look at the Rogers
okay we got him we got him got one life
to spare
rocket some power shot are good because
we can both hit him from range dead
already though oh he took photo I'm
sorry I didn't mean to do that
I apologize yeah didn't matter much
anyway I guess oh my gosh
[Music]
nope
once again get out of that 118 continues
left
all right
yep yeah this is the old blood did you
play the old blood I didn't so I need to
play back I went and I picked it up at
the end of the three they were doing
like a wolfenstein sale Justine Matta
for like ten bucks so I picked it up
[Music]
smart bomb Wow again nope
animal
this one's definitely the hardest boss
hey Jess considering we can't even get
to the boss
apparently I mean we've got we got
halfway one point I think maybe I don't
know all sorry - oh my god
up nope I discussed my backing hugger I
get mad
[Music]
Oh guys laser I can do laser [ __ ]
the power shot
unfortunately my laser has got to live
around hey human
[Music]
no oh look with no lipo got hit oh good
[Music]
okay shower shop that
[Music]
dang if we don't take care of that guys
you got to take care of that turbo right
away
whoa okay for my
13 Jesus never thought we'd get this low
I didn't either I was like oh we're good
[Music]
geez
[Music]
can't wait to see a youtube comments for
this one okay okay doing get them good
sword Wow
Laser third
get that guy yup yup you up through
let's go down here
grab the human school Moomin
[Music]
watching my pair right there
don't you care about anything else
watch my hair
Oh No
nope
[ __ ] up
what was that husky we need to tell my
dad and that also just made me realize
we that's the first time we've gotten to
the second phase I know
he's not even sted stuff yeah now he
isn't dead okay
[Music]
get them all right Scott and quick what
you got back this is Veda no this is
actually the full game ads out enjoy or
not okay well I was Cosette we did okay
but we've analyzed well use it okay I
did not
nope and I did that it's like that
happens it's just like that you're done
oh I can't imagine this by myself
what what happened I think I died in
wasn't it but I don't know how I gotcha
later on know if there's totally
reasonable explanation as to why I
thought I was not paying attention on
you buddy I can do this by myself
dude if you'd if you were beat this guy
right now I buy you lunch for a month
both she has lunch for a month is on the
line but I was just hustling really I'm
not for what if I was hustling waiting
for this moment I mean for me to make
some absurd bet yeah
[Music]
I'll make it because this guy's been
alive too long yeah it's like impossible
like once that guy right you just gotta
you got to get him right away like that
nope
[Music]
this guy right away and then I get hit
we're running out of lives here
good start
[Music]
okay got him to die he's out
everything
just you
nope no I'm here doing
[Music]
this is dump it on stage today though it
will be waiting
so it was at him and Mike something yeah
Mike bet yeah someone Testament well
Mike actually can be warmed up
yeah I think like Cooper II never got
him for the sign
I've given up I know we have four
credits but I basically given up I'll
put in the rest of my focus into these
last four lives that I print or nothing
[Music]
oh well you'll be back
Oh
now be nice custom range
Oh
related to lift we laughed think we can
do it no yeah no
[Music]
[Music]
okay
no way I was getting out of that
oh I got your laser I had a rocket cuz
Rockets like what you want with this guy
yeah Rockets entire shot to look down to
50% at least we did get him down to 50%
that actually did happen is that 50% I
don't I don't know if that run is 50%
but he won but the one with where he got
to the second phase oh yeah the
attention yeah yeah use it that's that's
the key
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa Oh
whoo okay
this I don't know what to do about this
I don't either
I don't know what to do it looks like
laser King or something alright this is
it I'm dead go yet I'm dead zoo rocket
launcher
this point couldn't care less about
humans oh yeah at least we made it
tomorrow last one actually might have
one more
[Music]
nope
thank you for the vet roblem give up so
it's not about giving out it's about you
don't have any lives left yes you were
out alive ah dang well I think that's
probably where we should end it no man
let's start over again we can see we can
do it on rookie but we'd have to start
at the we have to start at the beginning
of it and I don't know if it's worth
doing that yeah I think that's it after
all they're all right you got to see
pretty much the whole game though guys
but that I mean playing the game is what
matters and oh boy we got our butts
kicked at the end yeah this game is real
funded in the last 4 5 maybe maybe I did
let down the team this game is really
good scheme is very good it is now on
Steam and ps4 for I believe 20 dollars
it might be honest I think was on sale
on Steam - at the moment I really feel
like a little bit but don't quote me on
that
but anyway thank you guys for checking
this out make sure to subscribe and if
you are interested in this game
definitely worth checking out
that's all I got until next time see you
guys yeah gonna send you off with this
awesome music yeah
[Music]